[Music]
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
your family has a history of
philanthropy but as far as i can tell
you're not doing anything
the riddler is asking for you the killer
left this for the batman why is he lying
to you
are you okay
i've been trying to reach you
there's latest it's all about the wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
how am i part of this oh you're really
not as smart as i thought you were
bruised
away
all these years
lied to me alfred
we all have our scars bruce you're still
away
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know he's up to
delany
where are you there
what are you hiding selena i'll throw
your life away don't worry honey i get
nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it through violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on vengeance
let's get into some trouble
[Music]
foreign